this wave of globalization has wiped out
totally our middle class of all the kind
of rhetoric of this year's campaign is
the one issue that's why most effective
every night turn on the TV they say buy
this product buy that product well if
they want us to buy these products maybe
they better start manufacturing those
products in Ohio and America nobody's
kind of smoking up before trading for
the benefits of trade it's not a stupid
deal I mean it's it's really really not
[Music]
free trade took a beating this election
cycle with all major party candidates
blaming bad trade policies for the loss
of manufacturing jobs and the decline of
the middle class NAFTA is the worst
trade deal maybe ever signed anywhere I
will stop any trade deal that kills jobs
or hold down wages and it is part of the
race to the bottom the top target of all
this trash talk was the north american
free trade agreement also known as nafta
a bipartisan deal that removed all
trading barriers between the US canada
and mexico in the 20 years since nafta
economists agree that it's had an
overall positive effect on the economy
and its increased prosperity in all
three participating countries and
nowhere is this seen more than in the
state of Texas we came to Austin and the
headquarters of Texas Monthly to talk to
senior editor Erika greeter about NAFTA
and why free trade is getting such a bum
rap in a sense it's because free traders
work so long right it's because we've
seen over the past thirty years an 80%
reduction in extreme global poverty
mexico's consumer market is a lot bigger
now because in NAFTA it's labor market
is big too but it's getting smaller so
we're not actually seeing that migration
from Mexico at this point because
Mexico's economy is doing better but
that kind of also means that you're
seeing economic growth outpacing growth
in the United States and of course
you've areas that do feel dislocated by
globalization it's not really NAFTA it's
more growth of China as a global player
in the economy automation technological
change but it's easy to kind of point to
NAFTA a lot of the criticism you've been
hearing about NAFTA it's nothing new
back in the 90s when the legislation was
being debated Ross Perot famously said
now when you've got a seven to one wage
differential between the United States
and Mexico you will hear the giant
sucking sound no there's a political
lesson there's a business vessel but a
lot of these predictions haven't come
true regional trade has increased from
roughly 290 billion in 1993 to more than
1.1 trillion in 2016 and while foreign
direct investment in Mexico has
increased from 15 billion to over a
hundred billion in that same time US
exports under NAFTA have tripled in
Canada and Mexico now account for one
third of US exports according to the
Congressional Research Service many how
you do the analysis
one in five jobs in sectors are somehow
related to trade Jorge globalized
economy in Texas and Mexico have changed
because of NAFTA and you've seen an
evolution in both economies that's been
good for them both so there's this kind
of demo gosh concept that life is a
zero-sum game that you know the economy
is primitive that you take jobs from one
country and moving to another country
and then there's like in a finite number
of jobs to go around Texas is proof
that's not the case thanks to NAFTA
Texas has led the country and exports
for over the last decade in the States
GDP went from 444 billion in 1993 to
over one point six trillion today but
even though the state is benefiting the
constant nagging of free trade is
turning even traditional supporters
against deals like NAFTA the University
of Texas poll found that 51% of Texas
Republicans
that's right Republicans think
international trade deals have harmed
the u.s. the numbers out of Texas
reflect the nation at large
we're only forty eight percent of
Americans think free trade has been good
for the economy according to the latest
Pew Research polling if this sentiment
persists then that's gonna be adverse
for us me think I think is like the
opening of trade ties with Cuba the
expansion's of hang up now we're gonna
have a lot of economic growth in Texas
in the next coming years because of
trades if there's a hostility in Texas
to trade that's not gonna work out too
well for us the debate will continue
over nafta's legacy and as Donald Trump
gets ready to take over the presidency
and the protectionist idea spreads how
do we speak up for free trade it's funny
you know of all the kind of rhetoric of
this year's campaign just the one issue
that's why most affected the one issue
where people's views might have changed
in a sort of simplistic way to be you
know I was Pro trade but now I think
maybe trades bad or we shouldn't you
know we shouldn't make stupid deals but
it's not a stupid deal I mean it's it's
really really not we have also seen that
communities can dress it's not like
Pittsburgh and how much it's evolved and
change and that's in a much stronger
place than it used to be I think that we
should be looking at faces like
Pittsburgh
6ki Indiana which is done pretty well
it's possible for things to get better
even if things change
[Music]